brewers need a good one tonight from
hauser and he's been pitching well as of
late he won his last two decisions last
time matt on july 2nd at pittsburgh
picked up a win pitch into the seventh
inning now they're loaded up with nobody
out for joey votto game could get messy
quickly here if hauser doesn't dial it
in two balls two strikes howser still
looking for his first out and a swing at
a miss there he gets it went upstairs 95
mile an hour fastball vato strikes out
that's a big one for hauser early and
now get your ground ball get out of the
inning four seamer this time
up in the zone bottle weight right
underneath it and behind it good pitch
elevating that fastball that time
difference between the four seamer and
the two seamer significant for adrian
hauser here's tyler naquin now into the
fire early adrian hauser needs a strike
nowhere to put him another 3-2 pitch
swing at a miss he struck him out
back-to-back case for adrian hauser and
he went with a fastball again it looked
like the two-seamer it started on the
corner but with the late movement ends
up off the edge and naked a little
behind it underneath it again just like
motto yeah good pitch that started on
the corner and then tailed off and got
his strikeout well he's two-thirds the
way through another tough customer
coming up suarez pitch number 29 of the
inning back-to-back strikeouts red still
have him loaded 2-1 pits juarez a little
broken back little flare heroes got it
get yourself out of the inning adrian
hauser that was a lot of work a lot of
first hitting drama but a donut on the
board as the reds stranded loaded now
the brewers coming up for the first time
not really good for tyler malley even
better over the last eight games been
outstanding on the road he has the
second biggest home road split at era in
the game here's garcia bases are loaded
and there's only one man out 1-1
delivery on garcia here it is
or see a little
swinging bunt flipped to the plate no he
couldn't pick it up but a run will score
it was the only shot he had and if he
scoops it cleanly mally's going to get a
force out at the plate instead the
brewers have a run in on a little
swinging bunt by garcia well he rushed
it he didn't have to be so quick with it
he tried to scoop it and
get it over to tucker barnhart checked
swing
barely makes it to the grass
and just not able to get the handle on
it and flip it to his catcher garcia
credited with an infield hit in a check
swing like that barely makes it to grass
and he gets a hit in an rbi three balls
no strikes bases loaded
and he walks on four pitches two-nothing
milwaukee peterson who has been walking
a lot gets an rbi the easy way ali has
four sack bunts this year does have a
hit this season an rbi that's a good
punt
how's it going to go to third and they
get the out at third another nice play
by adrian wow spinning around making a
good throw to third
that was some kind of risky he must have
gotten a call from narvaez and he took a
shot gets the out what a play i didn't
hesitate either and urease acting like a
first baseman over there at third never
hesitated bare hands it and able to get
him good play on both ends good job by
aureus really skilled play by adrian
hauser well they're loaded up again
second consecutive inning for the reds
and now you got the tough part of this
order coming up jesse winker 2-2 pitch
and a swing at a miss it's another
strikeout where the bases loaded the
third all ready for hauser and two men
are out for schemer once again up in the
zone you can see winker behind it and
underneath here is nick castellanos
gotta make a big pitch here they're
loaded up two outs one two pitch and he
got it went right back to the spot man
the roller coaster ride early in this
game give him a stand and oh already
twice stranding the base is loaded and
doing it against an all-star starter and
nick castellanos two-nothing brew crew
he has clicked and been
lights out to end his outing and there
you go swinging a miss twists them like
a pretzel on a fastball up and in and
o'malley is retired four in a row
perfect spot for mali's fastball that
really plays well upstairs he's got that
kind of riding fastball with a good
backspin that kind of stays way up there
wanted to you could feel that rhythm
building for mali
right to the second baseman jonathan
india gloves and throws them out that
brings adrian hauser to the plate malley
trying for a one two three fourth inning
strike three looking at a fastball a one
two three inning with bookend case
heating up six straight brewers sat down
here in the fifth tucker barnhart who is
singled and fly to center gets his shot
wayne gets past narvaez
castellano storms home he scores
reds on the board two to one second and
third a 1-0 count back to it again
bounces away normalize can't find it the
reds tie the game joey votto home naked
went over to third it's two to two can
the reds take the lead here 2-0
barnhart cracks it through base hit
naked scores and the reds are on top
three to two the rally red strike again
what a crazy game he's got the pitcher
malley at the plate
cross between a curve ball and a slider
there's the tight one right there he
gets a call at strike three and uh top
of the order now jonathan india
and he goes chased one look how far
that pitch missed the plate but the
threat of it
and back-to-back case for cousins he
just don't get big league hitters to
offer it pitches this far outside two up
two down and here's jesse winker
broken bat long run adamus he's there
nice catch got a great jump willie
adamus able to run it down at cousins
with a three up three down inning
casting hero two outs
in the air left field back on it winker
can't make the play wow winker was there
and he missed it he just flat missed
that one off the hill the glove and the
brewers tie the game a game-tying hit
for
hiro what a crazy game 2-2 on garcia
garvaya's go ahead and run it first in
the air center field got it on the
barrel long run make when he's looking
up it is gone
avi garcia
two-run home run
and the brewers are in front in the
eighth this brewers bullpen has set down
12 consecutive batters
one strike away josh hayder 3-2 pits
and the ball game is over
waker has some parting shots and josh
hader closes it out boy it was an
interesting strike zone tonight and josh
hader benefited